I never thought the day would come in
which I would make a full-fledged devort
of logic video for an MCU movie there
would always be some silly aspects for
Marvel movies but never enough to the
point of justifying an entire video
however I think Ant-Man Quantum mini is
one of the most stupid MCU movies to the
point where the devoted logic aspects
were overflowing within the first 10
minutes of the movie it immediately
requires a major contrivance for the
entire story to exist and that
contrivance is Janet Van Dyne not
telling anyone about an extremely
dangerous enemy in the quantum realm
even when Cassie Lang brings out a
Quantum device that can send a signal
down there she doesn't warn them about
Kang instead she just acts like an
unjustified crazy person and haphazardly
pulls the power on this device as if it
were my mom unplugging my pc at 1am
while playing Minecraft
[Music]
it's kind of wild here that she isn't
open and explains her reasoning these
are all rational people and they would
most likely listen to Janet's warnings
given that she lived down there for many
years the writer tries to play it off as
Janet not wanting to go into it because
she's ashamed of the bad things she's
done and probably things that she can
get away with not telling them about
Kang which news alert you live in a
family that's obsessed with a Quantum
realm and actively wants to explore it
so you should probably give them some
warnings it's an inevitable conflict
that you can't ignore so yeah it's
obviously this way so that they can have
this malfunction and I honestly feel
like it would be better if Cassie link
made a design flaw and that's why they
get sucked into the quantum realm
because when you think about it Cassie
Lang has to be absurdly smart for being
able to make this regardless of having
Hank's journals like her intellect is
kind of swept under the rug and maybe
the writer should have explored the
carelessness of Cassie Lang wanting to
make a contribution to society and the
mounting pressure of her family all
being Heroes so maybe she cut corners
and rushes along this tack so that she
could feel validated in this family
that's hard to live up to given their
massive accomplishments personally I
feel like this already gives Cassie
Lange more depth as a character instead
of just being a generic good doer who
basically has no flaws besides her
getting arrested at a protest which
really isn't a flaw have her deal with
the consequences of sending her loved
ones to the quantum realm and have her
rise to the occasion and save them
that's a proper hero's journey this
actually gives her a tangible character
Arc and if I were to ask a winter Arc
for the movie currently is you'd
probably struggle moving along into the
quantum realm the entire setting is
extremely confusing and inconsistent or
it lacks any semblance of logic because
the writer doesn't make an attempt at
explaining anything within the quantum
realm some things are explained but
there's just so much random [__] that's
constantly happening in every scene that
it turns this movie into a silly mass
now this wouldn't really bother me but
the MCU is pretty fleshed out overall
and is based in logic like you can
generally explain anything that has
happened in the past with complete
understanding so the issue with this
movie is that they go full blown into
wacky territory and it feels jarring for
the tone I just have so many questions
like how are they even breathing here
why are there aliens that look like
broccoli what is the science behind
these floating ships anything regarding
populations how they even live how
they're making these cities and I can
really keep going on but you get it it
feels like Ant-Man Quantum Mania turned
into Rick and Morty which isn't a
coincidence because the writer for the
movie came from that show however all
the silly and unexplained sci-fi
elements in Rick and Morty are fine
because the show never takes itself that
seriously which I guess Quantum mini is
trying to be more humorful but it
normally Falls flat in my opinion and is
always kind of awkward
how many holes do you have
I'm sorry is that a personal question I
don't have any holes in the essence the
entire Quantum realm just feels like an
excuse to throw whatever the writer
wants on the screen and then for any
potential explanation they'll stamp the
word Quantum in front of it it's like a
satellite light for deep space or the
ocean but Quanah
there's
so basically the entire setting for the
movie is devoid of logic but it is by
Design so getting back to the story
Scott and cast here split up from the
Van Dyne dysfunctional family team and
they get attacked by King's Army while
they're with some Rebels what happens
here is probably one of the most
unappealing fight sequences visually
which is really sad considering that the
environment they're in essentially has
endless possibilities for how it could
look but for some reason it looks really
dull during this fight scene it's
revealed that Cassie has her own suit
which is immediately confusing because
she's been in life-threatening scenarios
on multiple occasions earlier on and for
some reason she chooses not to activate
her suits she had to be saved by her
father while free-falling they got
chased by a massive alien and she ran
around during this action scene in
normal clothes for an unnecessarily long
time why is this the case because we
wouldn't have this totally awesome suit
reveal moment it's also kind of funny
that Scott and Cassie have an entire
educational interaction about using the
suits while literally being in the
middle of the battlefield but luckily
King's Androids are comically
ineffective at the end of the scene
Modoc gets revealed in writing wise it's
really sad that he's a constant punching
bag for jokes it really undercuts the
severity of the situation and it's
really hard to feel a sense of danger
when this comical face is staring at you
visually I'm surprised they didn't try
to make the design of the face more
unhuman-like or is more malformed
instead of just enlarging it it looks
ridiculous and this character design
decision is devoid of logic to me I
understand that it's supposed to be a
big head but it feels like their
intentions were making modak look funny
on purpose since the writing surrounding
him constantly degrades him for humor
like I wish I could unsee the shot of
his ass and I did not appreciate being
visually assaulted this is just the
visual side of things and a story later
on gets laughably bad looking over at
the Van Dyne family their Journey
doesn't really have much impact on the
overall plots and is mostly the director
or writer playing out their fantasy of
making a Star Wars movie in Quantum
Mania though the things that happen are
so bizarre that they are straight up
confounding or cringe-inducing like this
random interaction in the desert where
Janet cuts off an alien's arm which buys
her a ship this broccoli alien trying to
hit on Hope
and the controls of this alien ship
having condom joysticks that Hank
miraculously knows how to fly at this
point I assume the writer doesn't care
about any of this making sense and is
batting away the notion of logic under
the guise of Comedy but I don't really
find this funny in any way and I'm
constantly in a WTF expression also
there's this really weird dialogue
interaction that is so awkward that I
don't know how it made it into the final
script with that guy I was down here for
30 years Henry I had needs oh my god
look I get it I've got needs too oh my
God I wonder if Michael Douglas had an
accidental crisis while reading the
script it's all this dialogue paired
with him getting sucked off by two alien
fleshlights so all of these scenes are
essentially driven by the mystery of who
this unknown traveler was at the
beginning of the movie and this mystery
is the opposite of intriguing because
everyone in the audience already knows
that it's Kang and what he does Janet is
basically teasing the mega thread at the
end of every scene and it's so dumb
because why wouldn't she just tell hope
and Hank earlier why wait so long they
were literally walking in an alien
forest for a while with not much to do
also during Janet's info dump about her
pass with Kang she reveals that the
Multiverse is real to hang which is
again kind of weird that she would
withhold this crazy scientific
Revelation from her husband who would
love to know about that she has all of
this reality altering scientific
information that she can do so much good
with that she for some reason withholds
now that Kang is finally revealed in the
narrative that means we can have a scene
between him and Scots there's nothing
wrong with this scene and I just wanted
to point it out as being one of the few
good scenes in the movie it feels like
Whiplash going from all the goofy [__]
that was happening to this scene but
hell I'll take any ounce of King at this
rate to move away from the annoying
comedy from here King threatens to kill
Cassie if Scott doesn't shrink down the
power source for his ship that Janet
exploded he obviously agrees and this
scene is kind of interesting but there
are still multiple things about it that
don't make sense for starters Scott
isn't a possibility field that splits
himself whenever he is met with making a
decision this exponentially goes out of
control and In This Crowd a Baskin
Robbins Scott shows up which obviously
is impossible given that all of these
versions derive from his current self so
the writer is making a joke that
completely breaks the logic of the scene
they then eventually work together and
act like a colony of ants which
thematically is cool but at no point is
this a clever solution because it's
completely detached from basic physics
finally This World War Z stack of
zombies falls down and hope flies in to
rescue Scott just in time how convenient
then together all their possible selves
combined back into themselves which
isn't explained and I have no idea why
that happened but they both shoot
shrinking pin particles into the core
and it shrinks now this is immediately
inconsistent to what just happened
before War where Scott fired a pin
particle and it did absolutely nothing
to the surface but hey if we fire like
20 of them at different points of the
surface then surely that would work
which it somehow does and it's also
convenient that it shrinks down to the
exact size that they needed it to be if
they shot it was 20 and it actually
worked this time then wouldn't it have
shrunken down significantly smaller than
what it is now Janet only enlarged it
with four pin particles so the math
doesn't add up or the barrier just so
happened to negate the perfect amount of
pin particles for the math to check out
whatever there's so many questions that
you have to ignore to enjoy this after
this king gets the power source for his
ship and instead of instantly plugging
it in and leaving he decides to give a
villain monologue to Janet which is
probably one of the most classic villain
tropes at this point and it's kind of
funny that Marvel are still doing this
31 movies in not including TV shows
during this monologue keng wants to know
what Janet saw when she touched the
neural link on on his ship which allowed
her to see his memories or whatever
however it seemed pretty clear what she
saw in the past and basically said she
saw him destroying planets and timelines
but for some reason Kang wants to know
the specifics I guess I don't know this
is obviously happening to stall for time
and Kang also makes a speech to his
Androids which these are Androids I'm
pretty sure and I don't understand why
he would need to make a speech to them
or why he would even care about the rest
of the population of the quantum realm
just freaking leave my dude not to
mention that you left Scott and hope
alive to come back and attack you you've
literally been waiting for this moment
for years and you're delaying your own
departure also a funny little moment
during Kang and Janet's interaction was
that she said trillions of people will
die due to timelines as a whole getting
deleted now I'm pretty sure that number
would be astoundingly bigger than
trillions given that we're talking about
the universe here if earth almost has a
population of 8 billion people then I'm
sure we'd be getting into numbers higher
than the trillions this was just one
tiny interaction that doesn't matter
right after this Cassie's being escorted
back to her cell and by some massive
oversight from Kang he didn't take away
her pin particles or even her suit and
she escapes that would be like taking
Iron Man prisoner and leaving him in his
suit to where he could fly away at any
moment the second this happened in the
theater I was shocked by how lazy the
writing was here it was also funny how
she enlarged one of the Androids and
this group of guards coming down the
hallway doesn't see him I guess also she
shrinks down in plain view of this group
of guards walking towards her so to add
to the incompetent bad guy Army list
they are blind have slow reaction times
and have terrible aim they are starting
to sound like something very familiar
which since I'm already making this
comparison with Star Wars King and Modoc
are basically like Palpatine and Darth
Vader especially since Kane can use the
force and utilizes energy beams
coincidence I think not then like five
minutes later Janet also escapes
captivity by herself at this point in
the movie I completely gave up because
if they refuse to put any handcuffs on
their prisoners and there's basically no
ramifications to being caught then there
is no danger for these characters the
fact that the writer did this twice is
flat out insulting Hank Pym gets
attacked by Modoc while in the
Fleshlight ship and it crash lands
luckily though Modoc doesn't even bother
to Chuck if Hank is alive and doesn't
confirm the kill kinda betrays the name
of modok since his name stands for
mechanized organism designed only for
killing so not even checking to see if a
Target who he also hates is actually
dead as wild when Hank gets out of the
crash she finds his colony of smart ants
that got sucked into the quantum realm
at the start of the movie It's revealed
here that the ants went through a time
dilation Zone that Minotaur they live
thousands of years and a single day they
created an advanced civilization and are
now a thriving Society who seeked out
Hank to save him this is probably the
most most convenient thing I've ever
seen in a movie and now the good guys
have an ant Army out of nowhere a
literal deus ex machina that they try to
downplay as being clever since Hank got
random transmissions in his hearing aid
or whatever but it was so much random
nonsense happening throughout the movie
it's hard to take anything as being
foreshadowing also these Quantum realm
mechanics are really inconsistent
there's just time dilation pockets in
random areas going back to Cassie she
breaks out the leader of the rebels and
the hatch a plan to hijack King's
broadcast to tell everyone to Rebel
there's a couple minor things here that
are questionable like Cassie not knowing
how to open the cell and luckily smashes
a guard's face into it which opens it
although this has contradicted five
minutes later when the rebel leader
inputs a code into a panel that unlocks
it not sure how she knows that but okay
and the other thing being that they
somehow know where the broadcasting room
is in this foreign compounds if I can
barely navigate Hogwarts with a
dedicated map in the bottom left of my
screen then I don't know how they could
find a very specific room in this
massive building that they've also never
been in before unless if there's just a
convenient map on the wall marking the
broadcasting room King then sends Modoc
after Cassie and he eventually best her
and is able to kill her but wait she has
plot armor and murloc decides not to
kill her and instead gets distracted by
Scott walking around in the background
like this is a guaranteed way not to
make anyone care about your action when
you know there will be no consequences
the even crazier thing is that this
happens again and Modoc chooses to talk
to Cassie instead of killing her like I
just don't care anymore then she turns
big in Rex Modoc they're following scene
together is probably the worst scene in
the entirety of the MCU tell me what to
be
[Music]
this is the worst
just don't be a dick forehead and then
he turns into a good guy like what him
sacrificing himself and quote unquote
becoming an Avenger is such a bizarre
turn of events especially with how they
treat his death scene it's so awkward it
tries to be funny when it clearly isn't
and then the music climaxes as an
attempt to punctuate the scene as being
a big moment when it's not at this point
in the theater when originally watching
it I looked over at my girlfriend in
complete shock and we were just like
what are we even watching right now I
want to put you into the Mind space of
Darren AKA Modoc this is a man who hated
and was trying to kill Ant-Man and in
the process God banished to the quantum
realm this turned him into a disfigured
monster and the amount of resentment
towards Scott for doing this must have
been unimaginable Kang then manipulated
this man into becoming a weapon and he
massacred thousands of people and even
loved doing so his mental slate should
be long gone from killing people for so
long and should not be salvageable by
any degree so the fact that he even has
this Arc to begin with is absurd I don't
think there is any realistic angle in
which he could give modok a being so
filled with rage and revenge for so long
a Redemption Arc and it's even crazier
that the change's mind a character just
tells him to not be a dick and that is
what made him change his entire
motivation Jesus Christ I can't so
finally we arrived to some King Carnage
and through his showcase here this is
probably one of the most glaring
examples of nerfing your villain in real
time he starts out completely wiping the
floor with these rebels in which if this
blue beam touches them they instantly go
poof however when he fights Ant-Man and
friends if he shoots them with his beam
of disintegration or whatever that I
assume like erases them from time they
just get knocked back so right away it
isn't consistent despite these two
events happening minutes apart and I
don't believe their suit should be
stopping this since they aren't made by
vibranium or anything also King has the
literal force and doesn't use it a
single time along with being able to fly
around on the platform like couldn't he
Force hold the three of them here in
this one spot instead of giving yet
another villain monologue then he gets
overwhelmed by Hank's ant Army and Kang
doesn't use his abilities logically when
Kang can use any of his powers like
flying away from the ants to safety
erasing them all with his energy beam
that cuts through people like paper or
even just force pushing ants away it's
crazy that he instead Ops the throw up a
force fuel that isn't viable to keep up
at all times this is supposed to be an
Avengers level threat and he lost to
[__] ants man that is by far
the biggest bicycle I've ever seen I
went into this movie hyped to see a
menacing and crazy villain who's
extremely powerful but all I got was a
buffoon who lost to ants how the hell
did this man conquer a Galaxy in best in
military strengths of entire worlds when
he can't even overcome an army of ants
who can only melee him up close we only
got see him fight for like a few minutes
and in that time it was a mess from her
writing standpoint after this battle
Janet opens up a portal from King's
device back to their Homeworld they all
get out but just as Scott is about to
step in he chooses to stay behind and
stop Kang from getting to Earth the
following fight is actually good and is
very visceral it shows the immense
strength of Kang and for once the scene
actually made me respect him as a
villain he's obliterating Scott in
hand-to-hand combat and this was really
one of the only things the movie got
right Scott realizes that he has no
chance and corrupts the power source
filling the portal and hope comes back
to help Scott defeat Kang now this was a
pretty powerful ending at the moment
because it was as if Scott was
destroying his only way home in his life
with his daughter to defeat the villain
for once an action has drastic
consequences but nope that notion is
instantly disregarded because Cassie
Lang is a brainiac and somehow fixes the
portal in like one minute flats this
essentially robbed the entire ending
from any sort of impact for me because
it erases the weight of this major
decision to destroy his only way home so
the heroes live happily ever after the
Council of Kings does make me excited
for upcoming movies but given all the
controversy around Jonathan Majors I'm
not sure what his future in the MCU is
going to look like so yeah that was
Ant-Man Quantum Mania I'm sorry this
video is so delayed my channel got
demonetized so I held on to this video
for over a month and waited to release
it I already reapplied and made a lot of
changes but I was still denied so I'm
going to make nothing off of YouTube for
the next three months to combat this I'm
starting a patreon and I would love your
support you can chip in whatever you
want and I'm grateful in advance if you
choose to support me it's honestly scary
to rely on YouTube financially and then
for them to suddenly pull the plug with
no warning I'll leave a link in the
description to more details about
patreon in the comments thank you for
watching as always and have a good day
thank you